there's somebody in there with a knife
runner at a new zealand supermarket
a terror attack is taking place
outside a stunned shopper is
broadcasting live
inside a violent extremist is stabbing
people man somebody got stand up
a guard tries to move shoppers to safety
but the attacker is known to police and
has been followed
within 60 seconds
he's shot dead
he stabbed this woman when she came out
i was going in i went down to the other
end there was a an old gentleman
european man lying on the ground
he got stepped up an islamic state
sympathizer we can't identify the
attacker under new zealand's laws but
the sri lankan national who went to a
supermarket with a plan to kill had been
on the radar of the country's security
agencies since 2016.
the individual was under constant
monitoring
and it was the police surveillance team
and special tactics group who were part
of that monitoring and surveillance that
shot and killed him
this isn't the first time jacinda ardern
has comforted her country after a terror
attack
a white supremacist is serving life
without parole for murdering 51
worshipers at two christchurch mosques
in 2019.
today the prime minister was once again
defiant in the face of hate
what happened today was despicable it
was hateful it was wrong
it was carried out by an individual
not a faith
not a culture
not an ethnicity but an individual
person who is gripped by ideology that
is not supported here by anyone or any
community
how i know an extremist was free to walk
these streets is still to be explained
once again new zealanders are on high
alert
once again they're determined not to be
divided by terror
siobhan robbins sky news